well brett jason congratulations it is
now down to the two of you guys battling
it out for the title of fortune fire
champion and a check for ten thousand
dollars in keeping up with the ninja
theme we're gonna have you guys go back
to your home forges and build a historic
japanese weapon we want you to build
this
the ninjato sword
the ninjata sword traces its roots back
to 15th century japan this short single
edge blade was lightweight and easily
concealable making it a weapon of choice
for stealthy ninjas to covertly
assassinate a target behind enemy lines
this iconic sword of the shadow warriors
can still be seen today wielded by
scorpion in the 2021 movie mortal kombat
so guys good luck we'll see you in four
days
my name is jason floyd i'm from amarillo
texas my friends would probably describe
me as pretty soft-spoken really
hard-working and really family dedicated
i'm here to forge some steel all right
all right so i'm stretching this billet
out trying to move as fast as i can i've
got this little sword where i want it
now it's time to quench this is kind of
the moment of truth the worst case
scenario the blade snaps that i can't
fix it and i'm starting over okay you
ready
so i'm coming out of the quench but i
see a huge bend in the blade i'm
thinking crap i'm not gonna get this
thing out of here
if i let the hammer up off of this thing
and it's still got a big bend in it i'm
gonna have to quench again
oh yeah i think i got it straightened
out in time it's got a little bitty bend
to tiny could have been a whole lot
worse all reality i'm i'm really pretty
pleased with where i'm at
we're going to polish up the copper
hibaki and do a patina on the guard i
kind of like the antiquish look
everything looks really good with it so
we're going to go with it just like it
is and get ready to test this thing
yeah i am finished i'm relieved
my name is brett south i'm 40 years old
and i've been blacksmithing for about
five years
i am a full-time police officer i don't
really use a whole lot of bladesmithing
in my line of work but i have made
knives for everybody on my shift it's a
good break from my day job pressing down
and my welds fail i've just got to get
something made so that i can move on
with this build
started over with some low layer
damascus i'm going to use some blue dye
on the blade and then i'll use my
calipers to mark out exactly where i
want my bevels to start thinking i may
go ahead and heat treat
i'm nervous about quenching in the fact
that i've never quenched anything this
long
we'll see what happens fingers crossed
i don't hear anything no pings no tings
no nothing everything looks good came
out perfectly straight and tomorrow
it'll be a sword
i'm not exactly sure what a traditional
handle wrap is so i'm gonna go with one
that i think i can pull off
and hope for the best
done
i am excited about the sword it was it
was fun to build and it was a challenge
and i'm glad the challenge is over
basements welcome to the kill test
it's time to find out how lethal your
weapons are to find it out i'll deliver
some lethal blows on this big carcass
breto first you ready for this i'm ready
let's do this
nice
all right brett let's talk about your
ninjata sword i like the weight that you
have with your weapon with stealth
movements you need something that makes
you fast when you're moving around with
that i like the wrap that you have there
i appreciate the stingray but it's a
little bit on the girthier side
i appreciate the damascus pattern with a
deeper edge and every cut was deep and
overall sir
little keel thank you jason your turns
are you ready yes sir you're done
all right jason talk about your ninjata
sword here
first up the handle construction it is
also on the girthier side but the wrap
that you have here is smooth there are
no hot points at the same time it's easy
to control and hold now i appreciate all
those layers that you have there
now your edge and tip razor sharp very
deep cuts on every stab on this big
carcass overall sir your ninjata sword
it will kill thank you
next up the strength test ben
blaine smith welcome to the strength
test the bamboo forest chop
remember this test is all about what
happens to your swords and not what
happens to bamboo brett you're up first
you ready yes sir bamboo is one of the
tests that i was afraid they were going
to do because it can just wreak all kind
of havoc on your blade and here it is
[Music]
hi brett the edge is just like when you
handed it to me the blade is still
straight
the fit up to the hivaki here is not
quite perfect there's a big old step
down here and these really should be in
line with the habakkuk top and bottom
your handle is big but it's comfortable
easy to hold on to so nice job thank you
all right jason you're up you ready yes
sir all right cool
very nice
jason your edge is untouched by the
bamboo as is the straightness of your
sword it's still dead straight hibaki
fit up is mostly there it's just a
little bit of a shoulder at the top
your handle subtly oversized but
comfortable enough to swing all in all
nice job thank you
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
sharpness test
the banner slice
to find out how sharp your swords are
i'm going to cut through this banner
brett europe you ready for this ready
[Music]
first up love the balance it is easy to
wield feels good in the hand
the edge is like hot knife through
butter overall sir you'll cut thank you
all right jason you ready yes sir let's
do this
all right jason it's a very light
stealthy weapon
it's easy to handle
and it slices nicely overall sir it will
cut thank you sir
well guys from where i stand it looks
pretty close but i don't make decisions
the judges do and they need a moment so
gentlemen i'm gonna ask you please step
off the fourth floor and give us a
minute
guys from where i stand this looks about
as close as it gets but you guys do have
a decision to make so doug what do you
think both weapons are executed
beautifully they're both deadly when it
comes to the handle though they're both
girthy handles but i'll have to give
that to brett because i like the
craftsmanship of the stingray and the
wrap ben what about you jason's blade
the fit up of the hibaki is pretty much
in line whereas brett's is a huge step
between the hibaki and the blade dave
where do you stand jason's blade the
pattern that he's got going down that
blade the profile the entire blade just
has that vibe so brett's blade he's got
a nice pattern on there but if you look
at it you can see all the sanding and
file marks dave you made your decision
yeah
ben yes i am how about you doug yes all
right guys we'll call them in
they're getting ready to announce the
forge and fire champion my freaking
stomach is in my throat all right guys
the judges have made a decision today's
fortune fire champion is
jason congratulations well brett i want
to say thank you for letting us watch
you work but unfortunately your time is
competition has ended i'm gonna have to
ask you to please step off the fourth
floor
good job
it came down to just losing to a better
smith so
no regrets made it farther than i
thought i would when i go home the first
thing i'm probably gonna do is kiss my
wife and daughter and then probably take
a nap
jason you just won ten thousand dollars
in the title of fortune fire champion
i'm a canister waiting to go off
man i just want foreign fire thank you
all a bunch i had a blast coming from
round one having a massive failure up
here at the tip you've got a crack
being able to fight back and make it all
the way it's been a hell of a journey
i'd do it again in a minute i can't
believe i'm actually the forging fire
champion
you